boa tarde gente boa tarde gente
depois do almoço a gente tem que dar uma
que dá uma animada e se não pensava em
dormir bom muito prazer que ele
primeiramente queria agradecer toda
organização do teste pelo convite dizer
que fico muito errado em abrir se ted e
o objetivo hoje é com vocês é
compartilhar um pouco de como a
colaboração é contribuir para mudar a
minha vida eu espero mostrar pra vocês
como a colaboração pode mudar a vida de
vocês e também os projetos que vocês
participam é que começar com essa foto é
uma foto de 2011 quando era
universitário ainda e foi uma foto em
que eu ganhei uma competição de casos
pode parecer um pouco contraditório nem
falar de colaboração e vou começar a
competição
na época eu tinha 20 anos de idade e eu
participava de uma série de competições
como essa
é com o objetivo de ganhar esses casos
basicamente recebi um caso na sexta
feira tinha 48 horas para resolver se
apresentar para uma banca quem conseguia
é ser o melhor é e quando eu olho para
essa foto é eu me lembro muito do meu
sonho daquela época
o que eu queria na época era
simplesmente ser milionário eu só queria
ficar rico era tudo o que eu queria
não importava exatamente o que eu ia
fazer não importa o que o que eu ia
propor à sociedade o meu objetivo
pessoal era ficar rico é e quando eu
olho atualmente essa foto eu fico
perguntando o que é esse sucesso no
final das contas é esse sucesso que eu
que projetava eu fico imaginando quando
olha para essa foto
será que eu teria sido feliz eu
escolhesse uma carreira de simplesmente
ficar rico
eu fico me perguntando será que esse
sucesso que eu projetava era um sucesso
que eu realmente queria ou é um sucesso
que é talvez a sociedade espera de você
e com essa pergunta em mente
eu vou pedir pra vocês fecharem os olhos
também por favor
mais uma vez sem medo eu tô vendo quem
está de olho aberto em
é eu queria que vocês pensassem também o
que significa o sucesso pra vocês eu
queria que vocês pensassem tentar se
lembrar um pouco da infância de vocês
você já sonhar em ser rico é puramente
rico seja sonhar em ser milionários
essa é uma questão que a gente pode ter
um pouco de mim e não quero falar para
ninguém quer ser um milionário
mas eu queria que vocês se alguém já
pensou nisso levantasse a mão pode
levantar a mão sem medo que faltou então
o amigo do lado nem vai saber podem
abrir os olhos por favor
como eu falei esse sonho vocês não viram
mas tinha bastante gente com a mão
levantada ele muitas vezes é uma
projeção do que a gente deveria fazer
mas em 2012 eu tive uma grande mudança
na minha vida que fez reavaliar o que
seria meu sonho eu me lembro que na
minha infância meu sonho na verdade
sempre foi empreender não entender para
ficar rico eu gostaria de criar coisas
novas propor coisas novas para o mundo
que ainda não existe sim só que quando a
gente fala de empreendedorismo qualquer
primeira palavra ou algumas palavras que
vem à mente é a competição porque
imprensa normalmente competem é e com
isso em mente
existe uma máxima que diz que o maior no
mundo empresarial sempre ganha do menor
no mundo animal é assim o leão vai comer
os demais mas existem duas ocasiões em
que isso não acontece quando o menor ele
é mais rápido que o maior ou seja ele
foge ou quando o menor é mais unido que
o maior porque o edital nem ele consegue
se proteger ou seja quando é mais
colaborativa ea gente só consegue na
verdade resolver os grandes problemas do
mundo a gente colaborar nesse sentido e
é por isso que a colaboração vem
ganhando maior espaço feito na
competição essas duas coisas podem
coexistir e eu quero mostrar pra vocês
como a colaboração tá ganhando espaço ou
porque ela tá ganhando espaço e
principalmente eu quero compartilhar com
vocês 5 aprendizados que eu tive
trabalhando nesses projetos
colaborativos pode passar por
é quando a gente fala em colaboração o
que significa colaboração colaboração
vem do latim vem de colaborarem é e co é
de conjunto laborar e trabalhar ação
tirar algo do papel algum efetivo
então na verdade eu vou falar pra vocês
como a gente consegue trabalhar em
conjunto para tirar os projetos do papel
e eu queria compartilhar ou então esses
cinco aprendizados com vocês que eu tive
trabalhando nesses projetos
primeiro vai passar quando você tem um
propósito genuíno você pode pedir às
pessoas sem medo
eu quero mostrar pra vocês alguns
exemplos de como as pessoas estão
dispostas a ajudar o seu projecto a sua
idéia se você tiver um propósito genuíno
então vamos começar com atados como até
meses explicou à tarde é uma plataforma
que conecta pessoas que querem fazer
trabalho voluntário com instituições
então a gente funciona como um grande
centralizador de vagas de voluntariado
facilitando engajamento social em 2012
quando a gente começou atados a gente
teve uma dificuldade muito grande de
entrar em contato com as instituições do
primeiro momento porque essas
informações estão muito de espécies mas
eu nunca vou esquecer quando a gente foi
na primeira reunião a gente visitar uma
instituição apresentou o projeto pra ela
estava muito incipiente não tinha nada a
não ser uma apresentação a pessoa gostou
muito do projeto agente pediu assim pra
ela você poderia por favor nos passar
alguns contatos de ongs que trabalham
com voluntariado que está tendo uma
dificuldade muito grande
ela respondeu para eu tenho uma dezena
de instituições que faz com que eu vou
passar está pronta pra vocês que eu fico
pensando se a gente não tivesse perdido
naquele momento como a história do
atentado poderia ter sido diferente
porque naquele momento a gente viu assim
sentiu na pele de como você pede e você
pode receber em troca e hoje só para
vocês terem uma ideia o atentado conta
com mais de 53 mil pessoas cadastradas
como voluntários na plataforma a gente
tem mais de 840 songs
que trabalham são parceiras no projeto
ea gente está presente em quatro cidades
do brasil são paulo brasília curitiba e
rio de janeiro
e todo esse trabalho de expansão do
atados não veio com uma infinidade de
recursos financeiros mas veio uma
infinidade de pedidos de colaboração das
pessoas
o segundo aprendizado quando você vai
começar
inspire pra começar engajar os outros
então imagine que você está começando um
projeto e você vai pedir uma ajuda
eu diria para você evitar de pediu a
ajuda dessa forma então estou começando
um projeto eu gostaria de ver a sua
ajuda porque não tenho dinheiro então eu
preciso muito do seu apoio vamos tentar
reverter isso e passar de uma forma
inspiradora então eu tenho um projecto é
um projecto muito louco é animal e eu
preciso da sua ajuda para colaborava
como é que é isso na prática é em 2014
três semanas antes da copa do mundo
a gente descobriu que era o dia mundial
do refugiado então durante a copa do
mundo no brasil tinha o dia mundial do
refugiado que a gente falou essa é uma
ótima oportunidade de dar visibilidade
para essa causa que ninguém falava no
brasil ainda no momento que a gente
decidiu ter essa ideia três semanas está
a gente começou a um pedir ajuda para
todo mundo e 2 contará a idéia desse
projeto que era um tempo quase que
impossível de uma forma muito
inspiradora a gente falava assim a gente
só tem essa chance
se a gente quiser fazer a copa do mundo
os refugiados a gente tem três semanas
então eu preciso de você
se quer ajudar é agora ou nunca para
vocês terem uma idéia a copa do mundo os
refugiados participaram mais de 500
pessoas
a gente teve mais de dez parcerias com
empresas é e conseguiu trazer
principalmente uma visibilidade para o
tema que ninguém falava na época então
pra gente isso era muito inspirador e
foi um evento que permitiu conectar e
inúmeras pessoas com inúmeros refugiados
gerando oportunidades pra ele também
3º aprendizado
conviva vai entender qual é o desafio
que você está passando então continuando
a história do da copa do mundo os
refugiados
quando a gente começou a conviver com
essas pessoas porque quando a gente só
vê o outro é muito comum a gente julga
lo
querendo ou não a gente julga a gente
pode ter a ciência de não ter um
preconceito mas de alguma forma a gente
sempre estar jogando mas quando a gente
convive com o outro a gente consegue
entender o que essa pessoa está passando
então quando a gente teve contato com os
refugiados durante a copa do mundo
a gente viu que a maior parte dos
projetos e um atrás das carências deles
o que eles não sabem não sabe falar
português que eles não têm ainda não têm
alimentação não têm moradia mas poucas
pessoas estavam olhando o que essa
pessoa pode oferecer pra gente qual é o
potencial que ele tem
então na copa do mundo os refugiados
surgiu a idéia de falar porque a gente
não transforma esses professores
refugiados em professores do idioma
porque eles já têm o idioma ele já tem a
cultura e muitos são carismáticos a
ponto de conseguir formar uma escola de
idiomas
então a gente fundou o abraço cultural
que essa escola de idiomas e cultura
gerando renda para os refugiados
basicamente a gente capacita eles na
pedagogia e eles estão aptos a ensinar o
idioma que eles já têm a cultura que
eles já têm gerando uma forma de gerar
renda pra eles que também é um grande
desafio que eles têm quarto aprendizado
e talvez um dos mais importantes que a
gente vem sentindo até o momento
toda vez que você tem um projeto procure
compartilhar com as outras pessoas e
procure criar com as outras pessoas
primeiro compartilhar se você tem um
projeto e você ainda tem aquela dúvida
do tipo a e não quero acontece até pra
alguém porque eu acho que ele pode
roubar uma idéia seria como falar uma
coisa para vocês nós somos 7 bilhões de
pessoas
você pode ter certeza que algum lugar do
mundo uma pessoa já teve uma idéia é
exatamente igual à sua então a pessoa
saber da sua idéia
é o ter uma idéia parecida com a sua não
é determinante para o sucesso do seu
projeto então compartilhe-o com as
outras pessoas porque certamente eles
vão da insight pra você
eles podem ser seus potenciais
colaboradores seus potenciais
investidores potenciais clientes
potenciais parceiros
então toda vez que você não compartilha
com alguém você está perdendo uma
oportunidade e mais importante que isso
é o cri com essas pessoas
peça pelas participar do processo de
criação porque toda vez que uma pessoa
está criando alguma coisa em conjunto
com você
o engajamento é muito maior porque ele
sente aquela idéia também é dela
ele sente que ele também está
participando da construção não somente
da execução estão voltando pro abraço
cultural
a gente começou em março de 2015 com
seis voluntários executando a ideia em
três meses a gente já tinha 40
colaboradores voluntários atuando desde
pessoas que davam cuidava da parte
pedagógica até pessoas na área de
comunicação assessoria de imprensa
até a pessoa na área administrativa e
quando a gente lançou o curso em junho
de 2015 a gente esperava ter no máximo
40 alunos era um piloto por conta de
toda essa colaboração que a gente teve
toda essa rede que a gente criou a gente
conseguiu no primeiro curso 900
inscritos
a gente não sabe o que fazer com tanta
gente no final das contas a gente
conseguiu chegar em 120 alunos e hoje um
abraço cultural já conta com mais de 28
professores e mais de 350 mil reais e
renda gerados para eles aqui no brasil
mas foi mais importante que fica falando
esses números é essa bela história por
exemplo da genevieve que é uma arte ana
ela veio para o brasil ela chegou aqui
chegou no lugar morando com cinco homens
também é de anos numa quitinete e quando
ela chegou aqui todo mundo que falava
para ela falava assim você mulher
haitiana negra do brasil você não vai
conseguir o país está em crise não vai
conseguir quanto à oportunidade de
geração de renda
você não vai conseguir ir pra mim saber
que o primeiro mês que ela chegou aqui é
o encontro obras cultural e isso de
certa forma mudou a vida dela é muito
forte também nesse projeto
por fim é último aprendizado que eu
queria compartilhar com vocês é ajude
para ser ajudado se você quer que as
pessoas colaborem com você colabora com
os outros genuinamente e quando eu falo
colabora diretamente não é o tipo rosa
país colabore e um passo a favor logo em
troca
colabore geralmente com aquilo e você
pode ter certeza que você vai ter um
retorno quando você menos esperar
daquele contato daquela parceria a gente
sente lotados até hoje de reuniões que a
gente fez quatro anos atrás que a gente
ajudou a quatro anos atrás a gente volta
aquele contato e falo nós atualmente a
gente pode colaborar de novo e agora eu
preciso da sua ajuda
então pra resumir é peça sem medo porque
as pessoas estão dispostas a colaborar
quando o seu propósito é genuíno
segundo inspire para esse começo você
precisa inspirar as pessoas e elas
querem entender sua ideia participar da
sua ideia terceiro como viva como o seu
público ou com seus desafios para você
conseguir ter uma ideia que realmente se
encaixa naquilo que eles precisam quarto
compartilhe e coloquei para realmente as
pessoas se engajarem você ter essa rede
e 5º ajude para ser ajudado
eu tenho certeza que vocês certa forma
conseguirem aplicar estes princípios
primeiro vamos ter idéias que de fato
resolve algum problema porque vocês vão
ter conversado com muitas pessoas e
aprimorada sua ideia
vocês vão ter a energia ea confiança
para dar continuidade no projeto de
vocês porque você vai ter uma rede de
apoiantes nos momentos mais difíceis e
terceiro você vai ter uma rede que vai
possibilitar que o projeto saia do papel
ele vai possibilitar que o projeto
cresça
a única coisa que posso garantir é que
você vai tirar um projeto do papel mas
eu tenho uma dica pra você tirar o
projeto do papel foi com a gente a falar
como a gente fez
toda vez que você vai fazer um projeto
procure assumir um compromisso público
então quando a gente lançou atados a
gente falou vamos lançar o site em
outubro de 2012 ea gente vai lançar
quando a gente lançou de um monte de
pepino de um monte de problema com essa
gente não tivesse feito isso a gente
tenha atrasado mais alguns meses e
talvez a gente tivesse desistido dessa
idéia
um abraço cultural a gente falou a gente
vai lançar em junho de 2015 porque a
gente sabia que em julho era o momento
que a gente queria fazer o piloto que
era um curso de férias se a gente não
tivesse lançado naquele momento talvez a
gente não tivesse tido esse boom de
inscrições e validada essa idéia
então se você está pensando em fazer um
projeto obviamente faça um planejamento
dele mas procure assumir esse
compromisso público porque existe uma
psicologia positiva deste levará a fazer
acontecer
no momento que você momento que você
pretende lançar o seu projeto
então eu queria na verdade terminar
instigando vocês provocando vocês a
tirar os projetos do papel
utilizar esses conceitos porque se eu
sair desse mundo que eu só tinha uma
idéia individualista de ser milionário
de ficar rico é quando você implementa o
seu projeto você tem um aprendizado
muito grande e é possível sim você
empreender projetos colaborativos
então fica a minha ilha minha boa sorte
para vocês
nos seus projetos os projetos de vida é
porque eu posso garantir que pra mim é
realmente mudou minha vida
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]